what's going on guys hold the door
Game of Thrones Season six just ended
with major fireworks a ton of stuff went
down some people are calling it the best
season ever and some people are saying a
different thing we're going to talk
about wet where it falls and what the
future of Game of Thrones is as it is
nearing its close and we have a couple
awesome dudes to talk about it with
first he's a producer here at screen
junkies he's one of the hosts of
watching Thrones you know him as the pit
boss at nap sock and this guy is a
writer of honest trailers an all-around
swell guy welcome back Joe star just an
FYI there's gonna be some spoilers in
this episode so if you're not caught up
you know just watch and then come back
that's how that works
so season six it just ended let's talk
about that final episode so much went
down burn them all yeah that was
outstanding amazing I didn't expect it
though I think we could have predicted
it based on some of the stuff during
that season but to actually go through
with it the way they did it was stunning
it was also cool cuz this was our first
big moment as book readers we didn't
know was coming I feel like this was our
first like because everything else like
mad and the red wedding you're kind of
looking at the the non book reader in
the room just kind of being like it's
gonna be great but this one this was our
first uh-oh no I remember book readers
would snicker at me and be like you have
no idea so you both like the finale but
you're a little bit divided on the
season you thought it was a great season
Joe um you a differing opinion let's
start with Ken yeah I think one or two
are in the contention for the best
seasons it's hard to beat one two added
so much to it but this to me was
absolutely a great season there were so
many wonderful big reveals answers and
spectacular moments that I think this
season will stand the test of time is
absolutely one of the best the way I've
described this season was it's like a
cat that always wants to get out the
back door and it finally got out the
back door and now it's too scared to
leave the patio it just spun its wheels
we spent way too much time with Arya
doing nothing with a with a regional
theater we killed off Rickon and we
killed off what's her face that's with
Rickon OSHA I don't care about either of
them
Rickon was the one stark death where
you're kind of like okay it was expected
he was a shaggy dog trope the story
doesn't matter was just a plot device
that sure that's ferrets it you know
it's a checklist thing which kind of
brings us to the Battle of the bastards
which I thought was a beautifully shot
piece of television but I didn't care I
really know in a way like I either knew
were okay that's just weird
we knew what we were going to get we
knew Ramsey was gonna eat it we knew
Rickon was gonna eat it we knew they
were gonna take Winterfell the show and
the story is wrapping up so we have our
own expectations of what we want the
resolutions to be and sometimes they are
what we think they are
I agree the Battle of the bastard it's
predictable still executed perfectly
well I was on the edge of my seat some
of the stuff you're saying Joe is
absolutely right about off the path and
they seem to not want to fully commit
because it might change the story
dramatically but then other times they
did Dorne not great but the end result I
can live with it because now we've got
an alliance that I didn't see coming let
me ask you a question to those people
who are saying that this is the best
season ever how much of that do you
think has to do with the fact that
unlike seasons one through five this
season didn't take one of your favorite
characters and then kick in the nuts by
beheading him or killing him it didn't
kill off anyone we really loved did it
hold the door how uh okay okay Oh door
is a very emotional death but you're not
wrong and your question is is I totally
get it because we got what we wanted we
got Ramsay being killed by his own dogs
why Sansa smiles yes we got Jon Snow
coming back to life when at the end of
last year the whole world was freaking
about kit harington's haircut and the
fact that johnson who might be dead for
good right and let me ask you this how
much do you think what was the producers
of the TV show saying like okay we're
done doing service to the books let's
just have fun with these characters
let it rip and have fun I think a little
bit of that I sometimes wonder if George
RR Martin's sitting over there New
Mexico goin I ain't released in the book
- you guys are done have fun it seems to
be sometimes a contentious relationship
a snobby snobby book reader i
emotionally divorce myself in the books
this year and said
I can't I can't hold the story up to
that standard or those expectations I
just got to see what they're doing they
know where they're going this is their
version of how it happened let's go back
to the finale and talk about this moment
that a lot of fans have been talking
about in the finale Jon Snow's
beginnings are plus l equals J
absolutely Tower joy sequence this is a
theory that's been going on since the
90s it was also introduced on the show
really in season 1 episode 1 and even
season 1 episode 2
he's my mother alive the next time we
see each other we'll talk about your
mother and if you go back to season 5
episode 4 were Sansa is in the crypts
with Baelish and she's telling the story
of how her aunt was kidnapped and raped
by Rhaegar and Baelish has given her
look like oh that's the story you
believed kid it's all there if you go
back and it's been building from there
so to finally get that answer there's a
little bit of wiggle room there's a
whisper yeah but I think we all know
what it means and to finally get that
nerd chill moment from yeah it was great
it was it was a fantastic payoff I don't
think we needed to stretch it among 15
different visits to the Tower of joy I
personally really loved it and was
satisfied completely does this all mean
that bran is now the three-eyed Raven he
is yeah for all intents and purposes yes
I'd still don't know what the three-eyed
Raven does look that's a complicated
answer cuz that's a complicated question
basically long story short he's a time
travel bird yeah I wish they'd just come
out and said that then three out of
raisin bran now you have to be out time
travel bird yeah why couldnt max1 see
now just say all right you're the time
travel right okay let me ask you
directly as a book reader with the show
outpacing the books how does that feel
is it weird does it is it fully
satisfying it it is weird and it's not
always fully satisfying I will admit
taking case-in-point Hodor Hodor his
death his backstory but we're getting
the answers we think we want and then
the show comes out and says hey we got
this from George and then George comes
out and says they did but mine's a
little different it kind of puts me in a
weird emotional space reading the
there have been so many moments where I
have put down that book and just said no
and I feel like now that I've had some
answers even if they're different in the
book I feel like now I'm just gonna have
more of a oh all right can you know a
lot about Game of Thrones in the books
and everything here's one question that
I'm a little bit curious about how do
people seemingly teleport from Essos to
Westeros I think the official answer how
is the show's timelines are a little
different than what we're watching
things are not as close in the time as
as we see it the real answer tunnels
there's got to be secret tunnels Varys
Baelish all these people in the know
know these hyper expressway tunnels that
are getting them to places that's the
only thing I can think of Joe
wormholes look man I have no patience
for even the smallest amount of dawdling
in this show and if the game of thrones
episode that you need in your life is
arya sitting on a boat for three weeks
so she can get back to Westeros we just
we just want different things
all right let's bottom-line it this
season where does it rank for you I'm
gonna put it number three behind two
then one then six gotcha you know I'm
gonna I'm gonna put it somewhere in the
middle it's it's given me some of my
favorite moments but overall is very
frustrating okay one more question
you know we're not gonna know this for a
while who's gonna sit on that Iron
Throne who ends up as the final credits
roll with their touch on the Iron Throne
look I'm gonna give it to someone who
keeps creeping into this conversation as
a keep our player at a corner piece and
every little bit of this show I'm gonna
give it to Littlefinger I have the same
answer I have and it's on record so I
can't change it but guess what
it doesn't matter cuz Season eight is
the battle for the world and the night
king don't care and I think when this
show ends Jon Snow he's gonna stand tall
as the man who destroys the night king
and the world as we know it esos
Westeros and whatever you want to throw
in there is going to be completely
different and there will be no throne to
sit on that's a great reminder because
Oh what is the throne matter if
humankind hangs
the balance who so much to look forward
to but really peter baelish okay we'll
see what do you think about this past
season who do you thinks gonna end up
sitting on the Iron Throne let us know
in the comments section what do you
think any other game of Thrones theories
you want to throw at us we want to know
can nap sock thank you for doing the
yeoman's work Joe star great to have you
my friend thank you for watching I'm Hal
Rudnick hit me up on Twitter my life
Batman and Wonder Woman recruiting
metahumans just give us a quick
description what is a metahuman it's
super as a superhero for a couple of
years Marvel and DC had tried to own the
trademark of the word superhero so
metahuman was a term that was used when
there was a debate over the trademark
yeah it's one of those words that it
really just means that these are people
who have abilities that's all